there's another law
they're not listening
the trade
problems that we would see if we didn't
clear
the ambassador bridge
would be unprecedented
absolutely unprecedented
as the world is watching
businesses
and people around the world
are wondering
is this a safe and stable
jurisdiction to invest
my answer to them is yes it is
we said ontario's open for business
and
we will always be open for business
this is not a time for divide in our
country in our province
the toughest thing
i can tell the folks out there
about this whole pandemic
is the divide
we see
from coworkers
from friends
and family
that's that is the toughest thing and
it's time
that we come together as a country
and as a province and show the world
that's not what canada is about
canada is the greatest place in the
entire world
to live to work and to raise a family
we're going to move forward
as quickly as we can
to clear the bridge to get people's
lives back to normal in ottawa
and we will use every tool in our
toolbox
to make sure that happens
you said it yourself that the protesters
aren't listening are fines enough to get
them to leave or are you giving police
the powers to physically remove them
well again i just want to make it very
clear
that i do not i repeat do not
direct the police
we make the laws
the police enforce the laws
but again uh we cannot
we and i emphasize cannot have people
occupying cities
holding them hostage
holding millions and millions of people
hostage
to go to their jobs and tens and tens
and tens of thousands
of people cannot go to their job
because they're being shut down because
the parts or the widget or the food
cannot get across the border not because
of the truckers because i can tell you
folks 99 of the truckers out there right
now are working their backs off to put
food on our table to make sure parts get
to the factories until we can keep the
economy going
the last count i heard at the bridge
there was five truckers the rest were
pedestrian cars
this is about a political statement
that's what it's about i think the world
of our truckers i support our truckers
i've supported our truckers from day one
but that is not representative of our
truckers the trucking association has
clearly demonstrated that they are not
in favor of this so again
to the occupiers please
go home
hi good morning premier collin demelor
from ctv news uh this is a pretty
consequential weekend this last weekend
in ontario you call it a siege ottawa
police said it was an insurrection a day
later ottawa police or the city of
ottawa declared a state of emergency on
saturday there was of course a
large-scale protest in downtown toronto
there have been a lot of questions about
you and your visibility premier ctv news
has obtained photos of you in cottage
country we've spoken with people who
took pictures with you who say you were
snowmobiling on saturday premiere can
you explain why you decided to go
snowmobiling during a stated
insurrection and siege in ottawa let me
make it very clear colin i've been on
this phone
almost 24 7
along with the premiers us ambassadors
the governor the prime minister around
the clock
make no mistake i have been engaged from
the second this has happened and i'll be
continuing being engaged
with the the authorities that we need to
talk to
fair enough but you are not
dismissing what i'm saying here i'm
asking you premier were you snowmobiling
on saturday in cottage country while
ottawa was under siege as you say let me
tell you colin i was at the cottage i
went out on my snowmobile
i take calls to one o'clock in the
morning i get calls before six o'clock
in the morning and i will not stop until
we get this taken care of
and i will continue to make sure we're
engaged in every
single uh area of our responsibility
premier richard southern with city news
how are you doing richard good uh you
mentioned the end of the vax pass today
there's a video floating online of you
being a bit more specific to that on
that can you tell us today sir when this
vaccine certificate program is ending
well we're going to take the advice
which i have right from day one from dr
moore
and i've always made sure
our decisions are based on health and on
science
and we put these uh this plan together
well before this protest started
and it's been a plan that we've been
working on for months we're waiting for
recommendations from dr moore i think we
all heard very clearly last week
and this week that dr moore
uh you know wants to move forward with
these these measures
and uh once we take that uh
recommendation we'll bring in the
cabinet and we'll make the decision
but premiere there's a video saying uh
purportedly of you saying i'm going to
pull the vax passes and that sounds like
you made up your mind sir can you just
tell us what that decision is you know
something it's based on what dr moore
said
the previous week and what dr moore said
yesterday
i can be very clear uh richard
that i will never ever
negotiate
that people that break the law that
people that are in there illegally in
occupying cities i base it on health i
base it on signs dr moore has clearly
said it's time to move forward i look
forward to dr moore's uh measures and
recommendations and we'll continue to
work with dr moore to reopen safely and
cautiously
hi premier charlie pingerton from
ipolitics um
how long will it be can you clarify
until these uh new orders are put in
place um
and when should protest uh protesters
be facing
fines the jail time that you've
announced today
well i'll pass it to our solicitor
general but again uh i'll repeat what i
just said i'll wait for the
recommendations what dr moore brings to
our cabinet we'll make the decisions uh
based on that and i'll pass the next
question over the solicitor general
thank you so as the premier mentioned
the initial declaration will be for 42
hours
the cabinet will be meeting
tomorrow to go over further
amendments and i think that you will see
in the spring legislative session that
we're going to start to deal with some
of these
safety problems that are causing people
to be
on public highways on public roads
putting themselves and the community in
danger it speaks to there is a there is
a wide difference between a
demonstration that people make their
point and go home and people put their
lives their families lives and
communities at risk that's unfortunately
what we are now seeing in
windsor and of course
in ottawa for the last number of days uh
over a week we want to make sure that
people can
safely go to work
access their homes access their
businesses and unfortunately
in ottawa and windsor that is not
happening right now so we we are doing
that with this declaration thank you
okay my other question is just
police have had a very difficult time um
trying to disperse these protesters
obviously that's why we're here today
what if this doesn't work what
next do you have as a tool to try to
resolve this situation and when will you
escalate things
well first of all i always have
i'll always support our police and i
have confidence in our opp our rcmp
and local municipal police
and i'm sure they'll get the job done
hi premier uh andy takagi with qp
briefing um i just wanted to ask you
there were reports yesterday that a
quarter of the trucks still remaining in
ottawa had children among them and
that's why there was difficulty removing
the trucks from downtown ottawa
i was wondering is there any action
being considered against the parents of
children that still remain
in the convoy and do you have any
message to the parents and children
remaining
as i said in my my uh comments earlier i
urge you
please take your kids home
please
get your kids home
this the the place for a protest
occupation is not a place for for
children
i urge you
take your kids home
and my next question is uh ottawa or
ontario turned down a third trilateral
meeting with the federal government and
the city of ottawa uh why not take
you know leadership in addressing these
protests and why wait until you're being
asked to act before sending in the mvp
well first of all we've been acting from
the second this has happened
when
the regions be at ottawa asked for
support from our opp
they ended up getting support i'll tell
you what people don't want people don't
want another table a bunch of
politicians sitting there talking
people want to see action and that's
what we're taking we're taking decisive
action to make sure we end the
occupation
and we get the goods on the ambassador
bridge uh traveling uh
back and forth
freely
without anyone impeding uh their their
transportation this is critical uh to
our economy and i'll tell you it's not
going to be tolerated in saying that i
want everyone to work together i want
this to be peaceful peaceful and we need
to make sure that we get the goods to
the facilities folks i i gotta stress to
you we're in a critical situation
worldwide economically
we have competitors breathing down our
back on a daily basis
we're competing against our neighbors
south of the border we're competing
against the rest of the world
and the last thing we need
is an anchor around our neck when we're
competing
these people need to make sure they
leave the ambassador bridge immediately
for the sake of hundreds of thousands of
workers millions of families that depend
on a paycheck going into these factories
going into these auto plants making sure
food gets distributed up here that's
what this is all about i want to thank
you and god bless the people of ontario
thanks everyone
you